-I want to congratulate you.
You did a special
with your friend, Steve Martin.
-I did.
-Was -- It's on Netflix now.
It was nominated for Emmys.
-It had many, many titles.
We have a new title.
-Because the old title was
"An Evening You Will Forget
for the Rest of Your Life."
-"Rest of Your Life." Then
we were working on new titles.
One was called,
"Two for the Price of Three."
-Okay. That's good.
-Yeah.
"Alive for Now," you know?
[ Laughter ]
"See Them
Before They're Holograms."
I mean, these are the --
-Yeah.
-These are the things we try.
-And you are --
He is a dear friend,
Steve Martin.
-Oh, I love Steve.
-Yeah.
-I love Steve. We're very --
We're like Trump and Kim Jong-un
without the sexual tension,
you know?
-Okay, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I do. And, you know,
he's -- he's so brilliant.
He -- He -- He --
He never gets writer's block,
no matter how much
I pray for it.
He doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
You know, he's --
it's an astounding honor
to work with him every night.
-Yeah.
-It really is.
I adore him.
-You -- speaking of, you know --
you don't talk about politics
in your show.
-No, no, no, we --
we do a little bit.
But, you know,
it is that thing of, you know,
people go to the theater.
And they've heard
a lot of politics.
-Sure.
-On television.
And, you know,
maybe they need a respite.
So we kind of don't --
we kind of try to do it evenly.
-And it's lovely because,
you know,
you know, you guys are beloved
all over this country.
And it's nice to be able
to do a show that
can be appreciated that way.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's nice. Thank you.
-Are you --
have you ever met the President?
-Oh, he's a chum.
-Oh, he is?
-Oh, no.
We're old buddies.
-Oh, wow.
-Oh, I love Donny.
You know, we sometimes...
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes, we'll just sit
and gossip each other.
We love to braid
each other's hair.
-Uh-huh.
-And when I say "hair,"
he has one hair.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's like that -- khhhhh! --
that thing.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, no, no, I love to,
you know.
And I went to --
I went to Mar-a-Lago.
I played golf with him.
-Oh, wow.
-Scott Baio canceled.
And they needed
someone for the fourth.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotcha.
-He --
Trump almost canceled, actually.
-Oh, really?
-'Cause there was --
It was raining 300 miles away.
And he panicked, you know?
[ Laughter ]
It's like the Wicked Witch
in "The Wizard of Oz,"
afraid of water.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-But you know
what was amazing --
you know, Mar-A-Lago is --
that's quite --
that's a white club.
-Yeah.
-Whoa!
I mean, an average member
makes you look like
a member of the Wu-Tang Clan.
-Really? That white?
[ Laughter ]
-That white.
Sarah Huckabee was there.
-Oh really?
You met Sarah Huckabee?
-I call her "Huck."
-You call her "Huck."
You're that close.
-You know what's fascinating
with Sarah?
-What's that?
[ Light laughter ]
-If you take her frown...
-Uh-huh.
-...which you mainly see,
and turn it upside down,
it's still a frown, yeah.
-It's still a frown.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Unbelievable!
Ted Cruz was there.
-Oh, wow, Ted Cruz was there?
-Not for long.
He just --
He came out and said, "Hello,"
and then slithered back
into the bush.
[ Laughter ]
But...
-You know, you mentioned how --
how white the club is.
But, you know -- you've --
you made this observation --
Steve Martin, your partner --
very pale.
-Oh, there's no blood
in that face.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he --
[ Laughs ]
he -- he looks --
he's the human embodiment
of Utah.
That's it, yeah.
-Oh, wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-You get the --
You get the feeling that,
when Steve was born,
it was not, like, you know,
when you open an aspirin bottle
and you pull that cotton back,
you know?
"It's a boy!" You know?
That's what...
-[ Laughs ]
-No, no, no.
The SPF on his sunscreen
is infinity.
-Infinity.
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
You know, that's a pale...
-It's a very...
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-You know, very, very --
you know, he looks like
a coloring book
that hasn't been colored yet.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know, I thank you so
much for suffering through that,
because your partnership
is such a gift to all of us.
And it's always such a gift
to have you here.
Thank you so much.
-Well, thank you.
I love this show.
You know...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I watch this show
every night of my life.
-Do you really?
-I do.
-That means the world to me.
-I think it is so smart
and so funny.
And there's no one more charming
and adorable and lovely
than you on television.
-Well, will you
please come back soon
and say that
exactly like that again?
-No, I can't. I can't.
-You can't? Okay.
-Well, I'm very close
with Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
But...
-Martin Short, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]